bonsoir à tous on se retrouve pour 45
minutes consacrées aux élections
régionales et départementales les
résultats les analyses des réactions
c'est ici que ça se passe et pour ceux
qui nous rejoignent je vous propose de
revoir les résultats de ces régionales
arrive en tête de ce second tour elle
est donc réélu lors de la première
session elle saura réélu présidente du
conseil régional de
Bourgogne-Franche-Comté sa liste arrive
donc largement en tête avec 42 et demi
pour cent des suffrages suivi de Gilles
plâtré les républicains
24,4% puis Julien Oudoul du
rassemblement national
23,7 Denis turio la République en marche
9,4%. voilà et j'ajoute pour être
complet que 94% des votes sont
dépouillés l'écart se resserre mais
Julien ou double pour le rassembleur
national est toujours 3e de ce scrutin
quatre invités nous ont rejoint sur ce
bateau quatre candidats c'est élections
régionales océan Charles Godard vous
êtes vice-présidente socialiste sortante
en charge de la formation continue
notamment vous étiez porte-parole de
cette campagne pour Marie guide Duffé à
l'insulinaire les républicains de Beaune
vous étiez 3e sur la liste de Côte d'Or
Christophe député européen modem tête de
liste dans le Territoire de Belfort pour
Denis turio et Aurélien du tremble
responsable départemental du
rassemblement national en Saône-et-Loire
où vous étiez vous aussi candidat pour
la liste de Julien ou double
et on commence avec Océane d'abord votre
votre réaction à ce à ce score vous avez
une large avance ce soir alors on s'en
doutait un peu vu les résultats du
premier tour mais c'est quand même
inattendu de gagner d'autant pour pour
le Parti socialiste on est content
évidemment c'est comme quand on gagne
une compétition qu'on s'est battu et
vraiment ce soir je pense aux équipes au
colistier aux sympathisants aux
militants aux jeunes au moins jeunes qui
se sont battus avec nous qui ont fait
campagne derrière Marie guide Dufay je
pensais si aussi aux équipes sortantes à
mes collègues notamment vice-présidents
parce que on a un bilan et je crois que
cette victoire aussi ben voilà c'est un
travail d'équipe c'est une posture c'est
de la confiance et oui ce soir on est
content voilà c'est la victoire de
marguide Dufay de la sortante on voit
que tous les sortants sont réels en
France au régional ce soir ou c'est la
victoire de la gauche
passer la victoire déjà en Bourgogne
Franche-Comté de Marie Guy Dufay et ses
équipes de la gauche puisqu'elle est
rassemblée donc et rassembler
sur un programme sur un projet et ça ça
compte donc on voit que ça fonctionne et
je crois que ce soit voilà ça a bien
fonctionné mais c'est pas la première
fois puisque Marie guide du fait elle a
dit tout à l'heure elle a déjà eu des
alliances avec les vers notamment donc
finalement ça s'inscrit aussi dans une
dans une histoire pour la Bourgogne
Franche-Comté Alain subnaut quelle leçon
pouvons-nous tirer ce soir de ces
résultats mais les républicains sont de
retour parce qu'il y a pas que la Côte
d'Or il y a pas que la Bourgogne
Franche-Comté il y a effectivement des
victoires un peu partout donc c'est le
premier parti de France et pour parler
effectivement de la Bourgogne mariée du
fait ça aurait été la pire des choses et
les sortants donc tous les sortants
étaient réunis en France et au surplus
on peut pas imaginer un attelage plus
large il manquait que la reine donc
effectivement c'était prévu ça pas été
au rendez-vous sinon il y a eu plus de
50% donc c'est vrai quand on a
effectivement ce champ large de
l'ensemble des possibles roses rouges
verts et normal qu'on fasse un booster
vous enviez leur capacité à rassembler
non mais je pense je leur vis pas parce
qu'effectivement il y a tellement
disparité de différence que je leur
souhaite hélas du plaisir je lui
félicite mais j'en souhaite du plaisir
pour l'avenir parce que il y a autant de
différence entre ce cette attelage et je
crains que ça soit à mon avis au
détriment de l'efficacité régionale
Christophe Grudler pas d'alliance avec
la République en marche est-ce que vous
regrettez toujours Marie guide Dufay
vous est claqué la porte au nez
important c'est de remercier tous les
électeurs de la majorité présidentielle
qui se sont déplacés dans des
circonstances qu'on ne savait pas facile
puis également féliciter un homme du
fait qui a remporté cette élection parce
que on est des démocrates et on est des
républicains donc certes peu de gens se
sont déplacés mais elle a été légitime
mais et donc il faut le il faut le
reconnaître quand j'entends ce soir la
victoire de la gauche la victoire de la
droite etc je crois qu'il y a un moment
il faut dépasser l'esprit boutitier ce
qui importe c'est faire gagner la région
Bourgogne Franche-Comté on a une des
régions les pauvre de France on a des
enjeux énormes et la pire des erreurs
avec cette nouvelle assemblée qui va se
constituer ça serait de revenir dans une
logique de boutique surtout la veille
d'élection présidentielle législative je
pense qu'il faut dépasser tout ça et
faire de notre région une vraie région
croissance et en développement et ça ça
passe aussi par le fait de transcender
un petit peu tous ces courants
politiques traditionnels vous parlez de
victoire de défaite c'est quand même une
défaite pour la majorité présidentielle
ce soir alors c'est une déception c'est
clair parce que effectivement on savait
quand on s'est engagé qu'on serait
victime aussi du vote utile et on le
constate de façon très nettement moi je
vois dans le Territoire de Belfort le
score que nous faisons pour les
départementales avec nos candidats au
départemental nos convertissons qu'une
partie pour les régionales d'ailleurs
c'est à dire qu'il y a eu il y a eu déjà
un vote utile sur les régionales dès le
premier tour auprès de Madame du fait
parce que c'était le meilleur emploi
rempart contre l'extrême droite c'est
comme ça que disait les gens y compris
les gens de droite qui votaient pour
Madame du fait dès le premier tour
Aurélien du tremble c'est une défaite
pour la majorité présidentielle c'est
une gifle aussi pour le rassemblement
national ce soir pour moi c'est pas une
gifle forcément pour le rassemblement
national c'est une gifle pour chaque
candidat chaque partie puisque quand
65% des électeurs s'abstiennent je pense
qu'autour de la table on devrait être
tous
restés serein et puis les pieds sur
terre et se poser les bonnes questions
surtout alors je vous propose
qu'on fait avec les militants du
rassemblement national vos militants
Valentins quel est l'ambiance sur place
et bien il y a beaucoup de militants
assez rayures qui partagent un verre
pour cette fin de campagne cette fin des
élections régionales 2021 il y a aussi
Julien Oudoul peut-être que vous le
voyez derrière moi qui est parmi eux qui
partagent ce verre on a vu un Julien
audoul assez rieur et qui plaisait
beaucoup avec ces militants rieur car
même si il est forcément déçu par ses
résultats de ces élections mais pendant
sa conférence de presse il nous a dit
aux journalistes il n'y a pas de
désaffection des électeurs pour le
rassemblement national il l'a dit
effectivement que sur les marchés
pendant cette campagne ces derniers
jours il a vu beaucoup beaucoup de monde
lui dire on votera pour vous en 2022 en
2022 tout simplement pour les élections
présidentielles c'est donc presque selon
lui un début de campagne présidentielle
par contre Julien doul a quand même tenu
et quand même tenue à revenir sur ces
élections régionales il a félicité bien
sûr la présidente sortante qui va être
réélu Margate du fait mais a tenu à la
prévenir à la veut dire que sa majorité
ne sera tout simplement par
représentatif car la population de
Bourgogne Franche-Comté ne s'est pas
exprimer voilà c'est un Julien doul
assez confiant pour la suite et qui
passe sa soirée ici à Besançon merci
beaucoup Valentin Chatelier Aurélien du
tremble Julien ou double rieur mais
confiant c'est votre état d'esprit à
vous aussi ce soir oui bien sûr puisque
2022 c'est demain on sort d'une élection
qui était finalement une non-rection
comme je disais avec 65% d'abstention
derrière bien évidemment moi je
rapproche les propos de Monsieur Odoul
quand on était sur le terrain bien
évidemment on a rencontré énormément de
personnes qui nous ont dit qu'il allait
voter pour nous bien évidemment pour
2022 puisque pour eux la seule élection
qui compte quand on voit sur le terrain
c'est la présidente
vous aurez au conseil régional vous le
rassemblement national on se battra pour
nos convictions bien évidemment et puis
en opposition comme ça a été par de mes
collègues depuis maintenant 2015 bien
évidemment on va continuer sur la même
lancée
oui Océane Charles de Gaulois
effectivement d'opposition ça en a été
habitué effectivement pendant 5 ans
avoir de l'opposition et jamais de la
construction moi ce que je voudrais
juste te dire c'est que c'est une énorme
claque pour le Front national pour le
rassemblement national c'est une énorme
claque parce que à travers cette
abstention cette exprimé de la
contestation et ça il faut l'entendre
effectivement et nous l'entendons et
nous nous considérons aussi cette cette
colère qui s'exprime cette colère qui
s'exprimait à travers un vote plutôt
vers les extraits mais notamment le
rassemblement national il y a encore
quelques temps donc on perçoit bien que
ce n'est pas en aucun ce n'est en aucun
cas en mode d'adhésion pour le
rassemblement national ces dernières
années et je pense que la claque elle
est vraiment pour le rassemblement
national et bien évidemment pour la
majorité présidentielle un insugnot
est-ce que la vérité des régionales sera
celle de 2022
écoutez pour l'instant chaque chose en
son temps les départements c'est
l'élection très importante on le voit si
les électeurs désaffectuer les urnes
c'est aussi en grande partie de la faute
de l'État c'est la première fois quand
même dans une campagne électorale qu'on
n'a pas distribué
jusqu'à bricoteur c'est le ministre de
l'Intérieur qui est responsable
l'organisation des élections donc à un
moment déterminer je vais chercher celui
qui est responsable on s'excuse
s'excuser devant les électeurs on
remercie les électeurs qui bien du
mérite puis qu'effectivement pas de
distribution dans le sud Côte-d'Or des
documents électoraux ce qui est
d'ailleurs l'article R34
si effectivement l'État lui-même montre
pas l'exemple et s'il fait semblant par
la suite de dire écoutez les acteurs
n'ont pas été votés ça n'ajoute pas bien
évidemment au climat et si au surplus on
mélange les échéances c'est le meilleur
moyen également en politicisant cette
élection au département télé régionale
de faire passer un scrutin important je
crois que si on est là c'est aussi pour
en parler quand je disais tout à l'heure
que j'avais des inquiétudes pour le
fonctionnement de la région continue de
la majorité qui qui sort ce soir il
n'empêche que nous aurons de notre côté
avec nous le souci d'être une opposition
efficace pas une position frontale c'est
pas dans le style de ma famille
politique simplement nous serons là pour
défendre les intérêts des Bourguignons
et les francophones vous dites
finalement maintenant pour les électeurs
du rassemblement national il n'y a plus
que la présidentielle néanmoins par
exemple en 2015 au régional vous faites
de très bons scores vous étiez en tête
dans 6 régions métropolitaine là il y a
un recul net je rappelle qu'en 2015
certes on avait fait des très bons
scores plus plus au dessus que
aujourd'hui mais je rappelle qu'en 2015
la droite et la gauche avait beaucoup
gagné quand même beaucoup de régions pas
nous en 2017 et là vous espérez
voilà la réalité donc en 2022 bien
évidemment nous serons ici nous serons
présents
je vous propose qu'on fasse une petite
pause je reviens
iens vers
on va partir tout de suite sur le sur le
plateau des départementales après
premier jour de la parole à vous
Catherine
merci beaucoup oui Christophe gruyère
vous aurez la parole après nous alors
donc je veux tout de suite rectifier une
erreur donc et arrêter de nous envoyer
des messages par par les téléphones
portables des textos oui le canton de
Port-sur-Saône en Haute-Saône reste bien
à gauche c'est le canton de donc où
Jean-Paul Mario ne se représentait pas
sa binôme Christelle rigolo faisait
aujourd'hui donc tandem avec Jean-Marie
Bertin et il gagne largement ce donc
quand on a Port-sur-Saône on reste donc
en Haute-Saône avec Vesoul 1 on suivait
donc ce canton avec beaucoup d'attention
puisque si présentait à l'ing-joyau dès
le sénateur LR du département et bien à
l'âge voyant des et battu avec sa binôme
Laurence Curie très nettement 40% pour
le binôme de droite est presque 60% pour
le binôme divers droites autre binôme
donc divers droites qui l'emporte c'est
le binôme de Carole Michel et Benoît
Thom divers droites qui ont battu le duo
LR donc un peu moins nettement
53,4%, il faut juste vous expliquer que
sur Vesoul ces deux binômes divers
droites maintenant votent avec la
majorité
discretinger le président divers gauche
de la Haute-Saône et c'est pour ça que
c'était important et quel âge voyanté
avait choisi de se présenter à Vesoul
mais il n'a pas réussi à relever le défi
Gabriel on va en Bourgogne avec vous oui
on va débuter avec la Côte d'Or je vous
le disais tout à l'heure à Dijon le
canton de Dijon 4 qui bascule de la
droite vers la gauche et bien on va
regarder deux autres résultats de Dijon
celui de Dijon 1 ou finalement le binôme
de droite a réussi à conserver ce canton
et dans celui de Dijon 2 qui étaient
détenus par la gauche et bien c'est
toujours la gauche qui le détient avec
la victoire de Nathalie kunders Nathalie
canders qu'on va retrouver d'ailleurs
tout de suite en direct de la préfecture
de Dijon madame kumpers
alors je ne sais pas si vous vous avez
tous les résultats nous ils nous en
manque juste un et pour l'instant on
arrive à 14 pour la droite et 8 pour la
gauche je crois que c'est Chenôve qui
nous manque quels sont les résultats
exacts alors le décompte finale alors
dans les résultats dans les résultats
que j'ai nous perdons de cantons
Chevigny et talents et nous en gagnant
deux Genlis c'est Dijon 4
quel Costa vous faites les résultats que
j'ai finalement on va avoir en termes de
sièges on va arriver à une
tout simplement la même situation qu'on
avait avant une stabilité c'est un échec
pour vous ce soir
[Musique]
cantons pardon pour avoir la majorité au
conseil départemental pour l'instant
nous on en a que 8 pour vous est-ce que
vous vous l'avez de votre côté le 9e
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire ce soir
ça a bien Bazin que vous êtes le nouveau
président du conseil départemental de la
Nièvre
alors ça on le saura jeudi au moment de
la session d'installation mais
effectivement aujourd'hui le mouvement
vivre la Nièvre rassemble gagne 10
cantons donc une majorité
comment vous est-ce que on a beaucoup
commenté peut-être parce qu'on avait un
petit peu d'émotion en disant que
c'était le seul département Bourgogne
qui pouvait basculer honnêtement on peut
en parler maintenant est-ce que vous
avez eu peur de le perdre des
socialistes cantons ce département
pardon
allez écouter encore une fois on est un
mouvement de citoyen qui s'appelle vivre
lanière qui rassemble des gens qui
viennent d'horizons très différents en
politique il n'y a pas de peur il y a un
combat amener nous l'avons mené nous
l'avons gagné nous l'avons gagné mais
avec beaucoup d'humilité et beaucoup de
modestie l'abstention est un fléau qu'il
faudra qu'il faudra combattre et nous
nous mettrons dès le mois de septembre à
la rencontre de tous les nivernés dans
tous les cantons pour avec eux améliorer
le projet de la Nièvre que nous avons
porté merci beaucoup
merci Monsieur Bazin donc nous allons
maintenant à Lons-le-Saunier dans le
Jura la ville préfecture du Jura où nous
attend le président divers droites de ce
département à savoir donc Clément
Pernaut monsieur Pernaut bonsoir a
priori vous perdez vous la droite un
canton vous en gagner un autre d'un
autre côté c'est le statut quo ce soir
quel est votre réaction
c'est un statu concerte mais c'est
surtout un immense bonheur d'avoir eu la
reconnaissance du travail effectué par
l'IS jurassiens et jurassiennes puisque
l'essentiel des des
conseillers départementaux sortants et
bien on bénéficier de score très
important d'une confiance renouvelée je
crois que cela nous permet d'envisager
l'avenir sereinement très bien je vous
remercie beaucoup Monsieur Pernaut merci
pour cette première réaction je vous
propose maintenant d'aller à Besançon
pour suivre la soirée électorale donc à
Besançon ou il y a six cantons qui
étaient à pourvoir voyons maintenant le
reportage de marine Candel et Marion
Ducros on regarde
à Planoise le stress et palpable sur le
visage d'Ali Hugo le candidat de gauche
du canton de Besançon il est ici chez
lui dans son quartier bonnet Hugo à la
proclamation des résultats c'est le
soulagement madame bonne
Nay
parce que je pense que c'est pas souvent
que on a des personnes qui ont mon
histoire qui qui arrivent donc d'un site
posture de responsabilité sur le
département un canton jusqu'à présent
tenu par la droite sur le point de
basculer dans un autre bureau l'avance
de la gauche se confirme il remporte là
aussi les deux tiers des voix
on est
unisfairecence les équipes centralisent
les voix l'avance de l'union de la
gauche semble se confirmer dans
plusieurs cantons bizontal ce qui est
symbolique c'est qu'il y ait l'union de
la gauche sur le tous les cantons on a
été présents ça c'est une première chose
c'est historique et puis ce qui est
symbolique c'est qu'après une municipale
qui a été très très serrée l'union de la
gauche aujourd'hui fait des résultats
qui sont largement largement plus
important que ce qui avait été aux
dernières municipales et donc c'est une
satisfaction pour toutes les équipes à
21h c'est officiel Besançon basculent à
gauche le binôme l'emporte avec 52,8%
des voix
on va rester à Besançon maintenant et on
va écouter Jacques richardetti c'est le
délégué départemental du rassemblement
national il n'a pas réussi à conquérir
le canton de Baume-les-Dames qui restent
à gauche on écoute sa réaction les
Français n'ont pas compris l'enjeu de
ces élections intermédiaires et
intermédiaires et non pas compris que le
département est la région c'était
quelque chose de concret pour leur
quotidien voilà c'est la véritable
faillite elle est là alors peut-être
qu'on y est sans doute pour quelque
chose on a peut-être pas assez expliqué
mais mais mais malheureusement c'est
comme ça mais rien n'est perdu il pense
que pour changer leur quotidien changer
leur avenir la mère des batailles c'est
la présidentielle alors la
présidentielle c'est l'année prochaine
avec Marine Le Pen nous serons là
tout à fait on votera l'année prochaine
présidentielle et législative et si vous
voulez voir les résultats de votre
canton n'oubliez pas notre site internet
d'où les résultats ils sont mis en ligne
à tout à l'heure Elsa merci Catherine à
tout à l'heure des images des réactions
Vincent tolé romain Libos ont suivi
Denis turio ce soir score décevant pour
le candidat de la République en marche
moins de 10% on l'a dit tout à l'heure
mais vous allez le voir les macronistes
ne manquent pas ne manquent pas
d'ambition quant à leur futur rôle dans
l'assemblée régionale regardez ce
reportage
42,5 10% des voix environ voilà la
maigre moisson ce soir de la République
en marche en Bourgogne Franche-Comté
près de deux points de perdus par
rapport au premier tour est-ce une
déception
forcément on est là pour essayer de
faire mieux
pour le macroniste pas question
d'expliquer ce piètre score par un
désaveu du gouvernement bonsoir Jean le
premier ministre Jean Castex au
téléphone le discours se veut résolument
volontariste
régionaux officiellement majorité
présidentielle quelques actions étaient
rapprochés ça nous permettra d'en avoir
et c'est pour ça que comme je te l'avais
expliqué me semblait bien qu'on se
maintienne ambition des marcheurs
obtenir huitièges dans la future
assemblée régionale de quoi constituer
un groupe et pas d'opposition frontale
en vue bien au contraire leur espoir que
Marie guide du fait fasse bien tout
appel à eux
elle en aura besoin pourquoi parce que
je doute fort que le tandem vert et
communiste soit un tandem aussi sûr et
aussi dur qu'on le pense il est très
sous tendu par des exigences notamment
des vers qui a certains moments seront
difficiles pour marier du fer à remplir
nous sommes là 7 ans de mandat régional
vont commencer le parti présidentiel les
bien décidé à faire mentir le résultat
de ce soir qui lui promet un second rôle
voilà il nous a rejoints
socialiste de Dijon on vient d'entendre
Marie guide du fait avec un les verres
et les communistes un tandem fragiles
votre réaction elle progresse énormément
là où tous les autres reculent elles
progresse à Dijon elle fait 53% des voix
elle rassemble plus de 15000 dijonnais
donc jeunesse bien sûr donc c'est un
beau résultat pour elle là où tous les
autres reculent la droite emmenée par la
droite extrême par Gilles plattret
recule le Front national recule
la reine n'existait pas la dernière fois
donc la reine est présente un faible
niveau mais elle est présente et donc
Marie guide Dufay elle elle passe de 35
à
43%. c'est une progression formidable
c'est dû à quoi son programme
aux capacités qu'elle a eu de rassembler
et il apparaît que quand le Parti
socialiste démocrate social-démocrate
celui qui n'est pas dans les extrêmes
rassemble autour de lui c'est le seul
qui puisse gagner des élections et c'est
ce qui se passe c'est ce qui se passe
partout en France
notamment sur l'alliance avec le Europe
Écologie Les Verts vous les avez pointé
du doigt dans le Journal du dimanche il
y a quelques semaines Stéphanie mode
allait dans votre opposition à Dijon
est-ce que vous souscrivez à cette
alliance là et avant juste pousser votre
téléphone ça fait du larsen pardon merci
excusez-moi je vous laisse répondre
oui bien sûr bien sûr je vous ai dit
quand c'est la gauche aussi elle
démocrate qui rassemble autour d'elle
sur son programme parce qu'elle avait un
programme avec une centaine de
propositions quand elle a un programme
qu'elle rassemble sur son programme
c'est clair que la gauche peut gagner
elle gagne pas partout la droite quand
elle rassemble autour d'une droite
républicaine elle peut gagner mais nous
c'est le cas aussi et donc là elle
assure rassembler et elle l'emporte avec
son programme avec son bilan et j'allais
dire face à une opposition très
radicalisée et j'ajoute que sur
dirigeons sur tous les bureaux de vote
de Dijon vous m'entendez bien sur tous
les bureaux de vote de Dijon il y a que
trois cantons ou Margues Dufay n'est pas
en tête et donc on imagine presque le
raz-de-marée que ça représente et elle
fait plus de 52% sur l'ensemble de la
commune de Dijon le 53%, 52 91 d'après
mes derniers chiffres très exactement et
donc nous avons nous avons là un
résultat qui montre d'ailleurs les les
départementales permettez-moi d'en
parler aussi sur des gens c'est un
formidable résultat
la droite j'allais dire qui qui fait
tout pour assécher Dijon et elle recule
elle recule elle sauve un canton avec
avec candidat sur Dijon 1 qui avait
d'ailleurs fait alliance avec l'extrême
droite dès le premier tour c'est le seul
canton qu'elle sauve celui où elle a
fait alliance avec l'extrême droite dès
le premier tour basculer le département
non je parle de Dijon donc on a 50 ans
sur 6 à Dijon excusez-moi du peu 5 quand
on sursis à Dijon alors même que la
campagne elle s'est faite sur non à la
bétonisation non à la construction mais
regardez le résultat le résultat c'est
que les Dijonnaises et les Dijonnais ils
nous font confiance parce qu'on est
sérieux parce qu'on a un programme parce
qu'on porte un social-démocratie parce
qu'on est des républicains et parce
qu'on ne veut pas de l'alliance avec
l'extension
quand on regarde le département de la
Côte-d'Or le Parti socialiste n'est pas
en tête c'est moins qu'on puisse dire et
François sauvedais renforce quasiment sa
majorité aujourd'hui mais si Messi ce
que tu dis pour Dijon je peux le dire
pour bonne c'est à dire que quand on
prend effectivement le rural on
s'aperçoit en effet que là le parti
républicain est là que les divers
droites sont là également je crois qu'il
faut pas que ce soir dire un camp a
gagné parce qu'au niveau national si on
veut en reparler je disais tout à
l'heure que les républicains sont en
tête l'art très largement au niveau
national c'est bien sûr le premier parti
de France donc ne s'agit pas de savoir
quelle est la chapelle ce soir
ça fait aussi partie de l'absentéisme
dont on parlait tout à l'heure je crois
que c'est vrai que pendant longtemps à
partir du moment il y a plus
véritablement de credo politique par
rapport aux engagements des uns des
autres c'est sûr que les gens vont plus
voter je dis pas que c'est le retour de
la droite et la gauche sur tous les cas
le retour des idées du débat d'idées moi
je me réjouis qui effectivement dès
cecialistes qui est des républicains qui
est d'autres parties qui interviennent
également ça s'appelle un débat
démocratique j'espère que c'est celui-ci
qui l'emportera en 2022
je ne laisse parler vous me permettez de
dire un mot pour contredion pour
contrarier juste s'il vous plaît une
réflexion que j'entends non mais
j'entends à l'envie soit disant il y a
que 35% des Français qui vont voter
c'est pas vrai c'est parce que vous ne
connaissez pas le principe électoral il
y a 35% des Français qui vont voter au
premier tour il y en a 35% qui vont
voter au deuxième tour ce ne sont pas
les mêmes il y a à peu près 50% des
français qui vont voter et s'il y avait
eu un peu de propagande électorale un
peu d'informations on en serait pas là
je suis d'accord vous auriez que
maintenant sur ce plateau
le retour la gauche et de la droite
c'est le rêve de beaucoup notamment de
ces messieurs en face de moi c'est fini
c'est fini ça la gauche et à droite
c'est fini maintenant si
Christophe gauche
c'est que c'est fini certes les gens
nous expliquer les gens ne s'y retrouve
plus il faut un nouveau modèle politique
dans lesquels les gens se retrouveront
alors quand tout à l'heure madame la
vice-présidente se permettait de dire
que c'est une claque pour la majorité
présidentielle quand monsieur l'absamen
se permet de dire que tout le monde
régresse non je suis désolé on avait pas
d'élus de la majorité
ont eu la grâce aux habitants de
Franche-Comté la possibilité d'être
présent au deuxième tour et on va voir
des élus qui vont siéger à l'Assemblée
régionale et ça me paraît extrêmement
important
va devoir gérer la filière nucléaire par
exemple avec quand même plus de 6000
salariés dans dans le nucléaire en
Bourgogne Franche-Comté peut-être qu'il
faudrait peut-être davantage d'humilité
et puis de de victoire modeste pour
pouvoir aussi compter sur les sur les
élus de la majorité présidentielle qui
qui défend la filière nucléaire et qui
qui sont extrêmement attachés sur
l'aéroport de doltaveau par exemple ce
sera aussi intéressant peut-être que la
majorité présidentielle puisse aussi
dire ce qu'elle en pense et et là
un programme elle est aussi des alliés a
eu et Adia c'est les deux dossiers que
vous freinez sont effectivement des
dossiers sur lesquels les verres ont dit
qu'ils ne s'engageraient pas avec la
majorité est-ce que c'est pas un
problème c'est un chat rigolard moi je
voudrais rebondir sur ce que vous dites
là vous êtes excusez-moi mais vous êtes
un petit peu gonflé quand même info sur
l'abstention parce que je me permets
vous êtes gonflé parce que vous parlez
de l'abstention mais enfin les plis et
les taureaux trop les professions de
fois trouver dans les poubelles dans les
commentaires
si vous parlez tous ensemble on comprend
rien exceptionnel s'il vous plaît vous
laissez vous l'interpellez vous la
laissez répondre
il y a 10 minutes
il y a 10 minutes et j'ai pas eu pu
répondre
s'il vous plaît la parole et vous me
demandez de vous
vous êtes grandiose donc je vous trouve
quand même carrément gonflé il y a de
l'abstention il y a pas eu de propagande
électorale c'est un scandale
démocratique ce qui s'est passé
d'habitude on a toujours des petites
capsules aussi vidéos à la télé qui
informe sur les élections et tout ça là
rien bon les professions de fois on en a
parlé je pense que ça révèle aussi une
méthode brutale et ce qu'on retrouve là
dans cette élection on le retrouve dans
d'autres domaines la réforme sur
l'assurance chômage tout ce qui s'est
passé aussi le manque de de dialogue
avec les corps intermédiaires avec les
territoires avec les élus locaux et
finalement c'est brutalité on la
retrouve là et puis moi j'ai envie de
dire personne ne t'ignorant puisque vous
avez une petite claque aussi derrière la
tête quand même au regard de ses
résultats
Océane j'aimerais que vous corvienne à
la question que je vous ai posé du coup
sur les différents avec les Verts il y a
effectivement certains dossiers sur
lesquels vos alliés se sont engagés à ne
pas voter ça a été accepté par les
socialistes est-ce que ça va pas poser
un problème le nucléaire dans le TA il y
en a plusieurs on a reprenez l'accord il
y a quelques éléments programmatiques
sur lesquels les vers notamment ont
demandé à un engagement encore plus fort
je pense à l'engagement sur la
restauration bio locale pour les lycées
je pense également à tout ce qui est
énergies renouvelables à la rénovation
thermique aussi
et je pense qu'on s'appuie sur ces
points des accords puisque ce qui fait
notre force et puis le reste
laissez-nous commencer à travailler à
dialoguer est-ce que vous vous sentez
pas un peu schizophrène vous êtes contre
les écolos à la mairie de Dijon et pour
Stéphanie mode et les Verts à la région
moi je me sens pas du tout schizophrène
je me sens pas schizophrène puisque on
le rappelle François hepsomen le disait
tout à l'heure Marie Guy Dufay elle a un
programme ce sont aussi les Verts qui
ont souhaité adhérer à ce programme il y
a eu des discussions et donc on n'a pas
transformé révolutionner notre programme
sous prétexte que les Verts nous
rejoignaient donc les vers rejoint il y
a eu des quelques points de négociation
on va commencer à travailler mais je
rappelle que c'est le programme du Parti
socialiste de Marie guide Duffy quand
les verres ne voteront pas est-ce que
vous serez content d'avoir le renfort de
la majorité présidentielle on verra moi
je suis pas médium alors vous dites
quand il voteront pas pour l'instant il
n'y a pas eu le
casier par Christophe williard
d'ailleurs
les écologistes et on a maintenu
l'aéroport de Dijon Bourgogne contre la
vie du département et d'autres et donc
il y a pas de problème quand ils sont
pas d'accord ils vont tromper sur
certains points c'est prévu et puis nous
nous dirons les choses enfin nous la
majorité de Marie guide Dufay dire les
choses enfin c'est quand même pas les
mêmes écologistes on est dans une
écologie très punitive aujourd'hui
l'effet Macron si on ouvre un peu le
débat l'effet macro c'est c'est une
bombe à retardement qui n'a pas encore
produit tous ses effets c'est une bombe
à fragmentation c'est à dire que tous
les partis aujourd'hui sont confrontés à
la à la césure entre les radicaux et
ceux qui républicain c'est vrai des
républicains c'est vrai des Verts il y a
des grunonnes chez les Verts quand je
dis des gros non c'est-à-dire ceux qui
sont les pragmatiques et puis il y a les
radicaux généralement et ceux dont on ne
veut pas et bien en gouverneurera enfin
Marie guide Dufay et la majorité
gouvernement avec ceux qui veulent et
puis on avancera ensemble il faut
rassembler elle a su rassembler le
devoir de tout politique aujourd'hui
c'est le rassembler pas être tout seul
il faut être dans une majorité incapable
c'est ce qui s'est produit c'est pour ça
que les électeurs le soutenus un
instrument a l'air dans douter non parce
que c'est rassemblement d'inclan quand
il faut pas exagérer non plus c'est pas
le rassemblement de tous les
Bourguignons beaucoup ne s'y retrouvent
pas ce soir on est d'accord et c'est pas
les mêmes écologies j'écoute ils avaient
qu'à voter
on a expliqué tout à l'heure qu'il était
le devoir de l'État et qu'elles étaient
les responsabilités tout le monde y
compris de nous tous on est d'accord
simplement si on veut parler de d'un
mouvement d'efficacité d'union des
Bourguignons et des franc-comtoirs ça
passe également certainement par l'oubli
de la part des écologistes de la partie
la plus prégnante qui est celle leur
programme qui parle d'édition de
correspond pas du tout à nos territoires
et je pense que quand Françoise semaine
parle de l'histoire de Dijon avec
certains écologistes le problème n'est
plus du tout le même ce sont plus du
tout les mêmes qui sont aujourd'hui non
mais aujourd'hui des écologistes qui
nous font penser à gouverner avec
Stéphanie van Françoise
aujourd'hui effectivement
je parlais tout à l'heure d'atelages je
dis je souhaite bien du plaisir à
François epsonade et à ses amis parce
que ça ne sera certainement pas le
programme tel qu'il est aujourd'hui
celui de la présidente sortante de la
région moi ça moi oui rapidement
François à Dijon on progresse énormément
permets-moi d'en parler au niveau
départemental à savoir que à part le
canton de Dijon 1 ou la tête de liste de
LR qui avait fait alliance avec
l'extrême droite au premier tour se
maintient à 52 ou 53 tous les autres
cantons basculent à gauche avec des
scores incroyables donc je me sens
conforté on va parler des
départementales
républicaines je voudrais lui dire la
droite la droite républicaine qui avait
emmené François sauvadel la dernière
fois elle faisait 33 % aujourd'hui la
droite de plâtre elle fait 25 % pourquoi
parce que la radicalisation qu'il a
amené imaginez qu'il a dit que j'ai géré
la ville avec des mots là je sais pas si
vous voyez un peu ce que ça veut dire et
bien il est sanctionné aujourd'hui la
droite extrême de plâtrée elle est
sanctionnée l'extrême droite elle est
sanctionnée je m'en félicite tous les
jours je salue moi l'arrivée de
républicain qui porte des idées qui sont
les leurs euh
tout à l'heure mais d'abord nous avons
l'intégralité des résultats de ce soir
et nous avons donc messieurs madame
l'hémicycle du prochain conseil régional
de Bourgogne Franche-Comté vous le voyez
cette émission Marie guide du fait la
liste de marguide Dufay aura donc 57
sièges je vous rappelle que cette
hémicycle est composé de 100 sièges elle
a donc la majorité absolue en de 6
sièges de plus que la majorité absolue
parmi ces 54 c'est 57 sièges il y a donc
8 communistes et 8 écologistes suivent
Gilles plâtré et Julien Oudoul qui
auront chacun 18 sièges dans
l'opposition et enfin Denis turio 7
sièges je rappelle que normalement
d'après l'accord conclu entre les
communistes et Marie guides du fait
avant le premier tour pour constituer un
groupe d'opposition il faut huit sièges
maximum minimum pardon c'est bien ça
océan rigola
il n'y aura pas de groupe
lrvm on commence dans quelques minutes
ce nouvel met d'abord un point sur les
départementales où on va entendre
François Sauvadet dont il a été question
à plusieurs reprises ici c'est à VOUS
Catherine
oui mais oui on entendra François
Sauvadet mais on va tout d'abord
commencer par les départements de
Franche-Comté on commence par le doux
alors déjà dans les départements en
Franche-Comté il n'y a pas de changement
de majorité donc on va voir département
par département ce qui se passe ce soir
dans le département du Doubs de cantons
ont basculé de droite à gauche il s'agit
des deux cantons de Besançon Besançon 1
tout d'abord où on voit que Monique
bonnet et Ali Hugo sont élus et puis
également dans Besançon 4 on l'a entendu
tout à l'heure donc George ubiali que
nous avons entendu et Jeanne Henry sont
également élus sur Besançon 4 passons
maintenant donc dans le département du
Jura et là en fait c'est le statu quo
puisque la droite perd un siège et en
gagne un autre la droite paire l'on se
soigner un puisque c'est Thomas
Barthelet premier adjoint de Monsieur
ravier maire de Lons qui l'emporte avec
sa binôme Christelle Platée et de bois
et battu c'était le conseiller
départemental sortant et puis à Dole 2
en revanche la gauche perd ce canton
historique c'était un canton qui était
détenu auparavant par les communistes
donc un autre canton qui bascule cette
fois-ci de gauche à droite nous allons
maintenant en Haute-Saône où là non plus
il n'y a pas de changement de majorité à
savoir que Yves cratinger divers gauche
conforte même sa majorité puisque donc
si le canton de Villersexel a été perdu
par la gauche donc au bénéfice de
Isabelle géant et Michel Richard tous
les deux LR les quatre
candidats sur Vesoul sur Vesoul 1 et sur
Vesoul 2 qui sont des candidats d'hiver
droites mais qui votent avec la majorité
de Yves fratinger divers gauche ces deux
binômes Sylvie manière donc est Monsieur
Oudot ainsi que Benoît Thomassin et
Carole Michel sont tous les deux élus à
noter que donc Marie Dominique Aubry LR
est battue ainsi que Alain Joyandet le
sénateur des républicains de Haute-Saône
et puis je vais terminer avec le
Territoire de Belfort ou là on a trois
bascules on a tout d'abord Belfort 3 qui
est passé du MoDem à la droite de
Bavilliers qui est passé de la alors je
vous laisse regarder donc c'est Yann
Boucard donc sur Belfort 3 qui prend
donc le siège du MoDem ensuite nous
avons Bavilliers qui passent de la
droite à la gauche
Erico berlait le maire de Bavilliers est
battu et puis pour terminer Giromagny
qui de gauche à droite donc en fait la
majorité de Florian bouquet président
les républicains du Territoire de
Belfort se trouve renforcé d'un siège
elle a maintenant 6 sages sur les 9 que
compte ce département et maintenant nous
allons posséder départemental en
Bourgogne oui pour la Bourgogne au début
avec la Saône-et-Loire la Saône-et-Loire
ou la majorité du président de droit de
sortant Andrea carry est largement
confortée ce soir la gauche qui pourtant
dirigée encore ce département il y a 6
ans s'écroule véritablement et symbole
de ces de cette chute et bien le canton
de zerzi ou la première fédérale du
Parti socialiste de Saône-et-Loire
Violaine Gillet s'est inclinée face à
Michel Duvernois et bien je vous propose
de les écouter tout de suite le
vainqueur puis la battu
le message qu'on a porté il
correspondait aux attentes en fait dans
les atouts qu'on avait nous c'était
cette équipe à 4 qui était vraiment très
bien très complémentaire bien réparti
sur le canton qui était interrogène et
je pense que les gens ils nous ont fait
confiance sur ces aspects-là et le fait
de
s'engager dans une majorité des
départementales qui a quand même fait
ses preuves en Saône-et-Loire je pense
que les habitants sont dit que ça serait
plus plus productif en votant pour nous
la première phrase de Michel Duvernois
c'est merci à tous mes amis je crois que
c'est un réseau amical qui s'est
mobilisé davantage que qu'un projet mais
je l'adresse toutes mes félicitations
républicaines vraiment sincèrement je
rejoins ce qu'il a dit ça a été avec lui
en tous les cas combat à la loyal
maintenant c'était de son côté le
rassemblement autour d'une personne pour
une personne nous on était en train de
mobiliser pour un projet ce qui est plus
long plus compliqué
et puis avant de se quitter un petit
détour à part la Côte d'Or la Côte-d'Or
la situation est figée dans le rapport
droite-gauche par contre la gauche
disonnaise remporte un nouveau canton
sur Dijon je vous propose d'écouter de
la réactions du président du conseil
départemental François sauvadesse viens
d'abord mes premiers mots vous le
comprendrez seront des mots de
remerciement pour les pour les électeurs
qui nous ont fait confiance et qui ont
reconduit notre majorité la Côte d'Or
passionnément notre majorité compte
désormais comme par le passé 14 cantons
et donc c'est une campagne qui était
tout le monde en a convenu très
particulière dans cette campagne les
côtes d'organes se sont pas trompés il y
a bien deux visions qui s'opposent les
côtes d'Orient veulent en majorité comme
nous une Côte d'Or d'équilibre que
chacun se voit un avenir là où la
choisit de vivre et cette aspiration a
une vraie qualité de vie et nous l'avons
tous en partage dès demain nous allons
nous mettre au travail au service des co
de tous les côtes d'Orient que vive la
république et que vivent la Côte d'Or
donc c'était François Sauvadet voilà ce
que l'on pouvait dire donc à propos des
départementales dans les 8 départements
de Bourgogne Franche-Comté aucun
changement de majorité départementale à
Elsa Catherine et merci aussi à Gabriel
talon Christophe Gru de l'air est-ce que
ces résultats bouscule le paysage
politique à moins d'un an de la
présidentielle alors pas vraiment
puisque voilà il y a la prime en sortant
tout le monde est reconduit donc ça
bouscule pas nous pour la majorité
présidentielle ça nous a permis d'être
représentés maintenant dans les régions
on savait que ça serait pas facile et
maintenant on existe dans ces régions et
il faut maintenant poursuivre l'encrage
territorial on s'est aperçu qu'avec
clairement des manques dans certaines
zones dans certains départements et donc
on a maintenant un an pour corriger tout
ça pour être bien vraiment implanté de
façon uniforme sur l'ensemble la
Bourgogne Franche-Comté puis pour être
prêt pour les échéances suivantes c'est
toujours des marches de l'escalier tout
ça et dans bonne disposition là ce soir
pour lancer sa campagne présidentielle
je vous demande ce que vous moi je pense
que ce soir grâce à ce qui se passe
très nombreuses régions de France on n'a
jamais eu autant d'élus départementaux
et régionaux donc c'est à partir de ce
socle là qu'il faut construire et si on
n'avait pas eu le courage d'aller dans
ces régions il y aura pas eu de socle
donc maintenant il y a ce socle c'est un
moment pas très facile les gens étaient
présents les gens étaient également
présents dans les bureaux de vote en
tant qu'assesseur délégué vraiment un
gros travail qui a été effectué et donc
c'est porteur d'avenir vous êtes
d'accord François
e je veux pas minerai ou majorer le
résultat de de la République en marche
il y a pas de partie en marche ça
n'existe pas là il y a le MoDem qui est
présent mais tout le monde sait bien que
le parti en marche il a explosé il
n'existe pas en réalité ce soir avant la
présidentielle la gauche elle retrouve
des couleurs quand elle est capable sur
un programme ce qui s'est passé en
Bourgogne Franche-Comté sur un programme
avec des représentants qui sont
qualifiés de rassembler autour d'elle
sur son programme et quand c'est la
gauche social-démocrate c'est à dire que
ce sont des socialistes qui mènent ces
listes d'ailleurs on le voit partout en
France quand il y a une compétition
entre la gauche sociale démocrate et des
socialistes et des et des écologistes
pardon c'est toujours les socialistes
qui l'emportent regardez Carole d'Elia
elle fait près 57 ou 58 ou 59 par
exemple Bayou il est devant la liste
soutenue par le PS en Île-de-France
il était avec vous dites une bêtise mais
c'est le premier tour elle est devant
puisque c'est lui qui mène la liste
34%, c'est-à-dire pas grand chose ce que
je dis aujourd'hui c'est que les seuls
qui sont en mesure de gagner ça sera
vrai demain pour la présidentielle ça
veut pas dire qu'on gagnera mais les
seuls qui sont en mesure de gagner c'est
quand le centre de la gauche
c'est-à-dire les socialistes avec leur
valeur de l'associé à l'écologie
rassemble sur un programme autour d'eux
c'est ce qui nous reste à faire c'est il
y a du travail parce que on arrive en
terme de la partie régionale de cette
soirée électorale je vous redonne les
scores définitifs de l'élection
régionale en Bourgogne Franche-Comté la
liste de Mary guide Dufay arrive en tête
avec 42,2 % des suffrages devant la
liste de Gilles plattret
24,2%, Julien endouble du rassemblement
national
23,8 et Denis thuriaux
9,8% des voix ça donnera une majorité de
57 sièges sur 100 sièges à mary-gite
Dufay merci merci à vous tous d'être
venu débattre sur ce plateau merci à
toutes les équipes de France 3 mobilisés
ce soir pour vous faire vivre cette
grande soirée électorale on se donne
rendez-vous demain à partir de 11h50 et
18h30 pour aider les éditions spéciales
merci très belle fin de soirée à vous
merci joie merci merci
[Musique]